[MUSIC PLAYING]
Racing teams do a great job of
being at the cutting edge of
technology.
And what we're doing here at
Caterpillar, putting diesel
engines into machines
like this,
is also a huge challenge.
A Formula 1 engine idles at a
higher speed than the top
speed of one of these engines,
but we can easily produce
double the amount of torque.
Fuel economy is a huge issue.
Moving hundreds of cubic metres
of dirt a day is going
to burn a lot of diesel.
And if you can reduce that by
even a fraction, well the
savings annually are huge.
So here in our engine test
facility, we're doing all the
things you'd expect a racing
team to be doing.
Any development we dream up in
the design office, we have to
validate here on real engines,
before it can go into
production.
So here we have our test cell.
And inside, you can
see we have an
engine ready to be tested.
You can see that we have all the
required safety features,
and also all the temperature
and pressure measurements.
You can see up at the to we
have our air inlet and our
exhaust going in and out
of the test cell.
Around the side, you can see
the coolant that we have
required for the engine.
And around the back, you can
see our two-stage series
turbochargers.
So take these turbochargers
and say we want to make a
design change.
First of all, we model
the design.
But we have to validate
that model.
So here in the test lab, we
run a baseline engine
configuration, taking all the
measurements that we require.
So you then go back to the model
and look at different
designs and create a
computational prediction on
how the air flow is going to
improved through the engine,
thus improving the combustion
efficiency and overall
efficiency of the engine.
So you only have to go back
to the engine for a final
calibration, validation,
and endurance test.
All of this reduces the amount
of engine testing
that we have to do.
This sort of test facility is
just as crucial to heavyweight
construction equipment
as it is to
featherweight racing cars.
[MUSIC PLAYING]